um let me know what you guys
uh here let's see out here we are now
live
on the into the impossible podcast i am
going to begin
by welcoming everybody uh to the into
the impossible podcast and
to celebrate coming up on almost 100
episodes
we are i believe at 98 currently now
i'm going to play a theme song written
by a friend of mine
who goes by the moniker yeti tears and
this is miguel
and he made this lovely song so let's
see if we can hear it
[Music]
do
yeah that worked all right everybody so
that is my cool new edition
an early hanukkah present from me from
from my friend mr miguel at yeti tears
is a phenomenal musician
i want to thank him for doing that uh
we're getting all sorts of cool stuff
uh happening on the podcast we'll talk
about that later but today i'm super
excited to talk to these
two gentlemen and these two gentlemen
astronomers have written a wonderful
book called
the cosmic revolutionaries handbook i
thought this was
bernie sanders science policy platform
but actually no it is about what i study
and i want to introduce the two authors
to doctors
including uh professor gerald uh lewis
who is there
hello jared say hello to the into the
impossible audience of
dozens hello everybody how's it going
and then his counterpart luke barnes dr
luke barnes who is an astronomer
also you guys are joining us bright and
early or extremely late in australia
what is it
what time is it now nine in the morning
i am
okay well that's that's pretty uh
relaxing but it's a day ahead so
you you can tell me what's happening in
advance
um tomorrow is pretty nice tomorrow's
pretty what are the lottery numbers i
should play tomorrow
uh so we're going to be talking as i
said about this phenomenal book called
the cosmic revolutionaries handbook
with incomia uh presented by
none other than uh people such as sean
carroll dr sean carroll and dr
primavadya narjin who's known as priya
to those who love her at
yale university and uh she
and sean provide a deep loving and
raving incomia for your fine book
i want to start by asking you you won't
know this i don't think you know this
but the
person who previously occupied the very
space
that i'm speaking to you from as we
speak
is uh is dr jeff burbidge now
if there was ever a cosmic revolutionary
it was jeff burbidge you mentioned him
in the book
and of course he had many ideas outside
the mainstream of cosmology that i want
to get into
but first i wanted to just bid you uh
greetings from
jeff berbich's office behind me over my
shoulder you see a picture taken by his
wife that's margaret burbidge
who is one of the most towering
astronomers of the previous
uh generation she passed away this year
earlier in 2020
at the ripe old age of a hundred she was
not as revolutionary as her husband and
partner
uh jeff burbidge but also uh much more
uh
interested in sort of i would say
orthodox ideas
but i first want to ask you why bother
writing about the ways the big bang
could be wrong
when we each probably get a fair number
of emails every day stating and
attesting to
a newly previously undiscovered theory
of the universe why do we need a book
about
how to overcome the big mac
um well precisely for that reason that
you just said um
luke and i give a lot of public talks
and astronomy and cosmology
and after the talk as you know you get
lots of great questions especially from
the kids
but in the audience always somewhere at
the back there's a retired gentleman
they're normally a man they're normally
an engineer
and they basically think that we're
wrong that they don't
like this notion of a universe that was
born 14 billion years ago that's
expanding et cetera
and they know the truth right they have
the right idea they know
where we've gone wrong and how to put it
right but they just
they want to know why why don't why
don't astronomers cosmos just
listen to them so we we actually got
tired of answering the same questions
over and over again so we thought we'd
lay out in book form
what we thought the process you would
have to take to really overthrow the big
bang
and luke what was uh in it for you i i
would worry if
i was a younger person in my career that
i might get tainted
with the with the with the stench of
revolution in the air
uh what gave you the courage to go as we
say into the impossible and
and co-author such a such a marvelous
little book
uh well to be honest this one's nothing
compared to our last book
unfortunate universe but we can talk
about that another time um
so as garen said we kept we kept getting
emails from people
and and questions from people telling us
how to do our job
and we kept if you can find the time to
reply you send very similar emails every
time
it's you know thank you uh
but you have to explain more than one
bit of information
in order to have a successful model
thank you but
when you say i know my idea is right i
just need some help with the mathematics
what that means is you don't know
whether your idea is right because you
haven't predicted anything yet
and after you've sort of given those
sorts of replies a whole bunch of times
um you know there's the idea of a book
there that instead of sending that same
email again we can just say hey
why don't you go and buy our book
yes of course that's always something
that i love it when authors are
interviewed on podcasts
and you probably had this happen on many
of your podcast interviewers
but they say can you tell us the thesis
of your book uh chapter by chapter
summary uh
and basically save our customers or our
listeners the trouble of buying your
book but
i agree i get a lot of emails about that
even today i've received over three
emails about new theories of everything
or theories of the big bang uh being
wrong and it can be proven without any
math and if i do
uh they will not only share the uh
authorship second authorship
but they will also share some of the
nobel prize that is won
from their new discovery and i'm sure
you get that a lot and speaking of nobel
prizes so my audience out there
uh i have the opportunity to have on
frank wilcheck who won the nobel prize
in 2004 uh along with uh with
uh his his colleagues gross and and
pulitzer
um but i will only have this as a live
stream
if you my audience can help get to 15
000 subscribers we are now at
14 900 or so uh so please share the
wealth uh spread it around so that luke
and and grant
can be sandwiched between shelley
glacial my previous interview
and frank wilcheck and hopefully they
too will benefit from this very golden
medallion
that we love and know so please yes i
want to get i want to do a live chat but
only if we hit 15 000 subscribers by 9
a.m pacific tomorrow
anyway boys back to you this book is
awesome because
it presents things in a in a respectful
way you don't insult the people that
want to come up with new ideas
you don't make fun of them you merely
provide
i would say a rubric and at the at the
end of the hour we'll go through a
rubric of of
alternate models to the big bang which
is the only lacuna
in this book is that you didn't really
go through and harpoon like all these
different models of the universe
of which there are many and some of
which i've had guest espouse on my own
show
and will indeed in the future when i
have on more guests such as garrett lisi
who's got a model of the universe as a
deformed lead group but i want to start
with uh something i didn't know
which you alerted me to in this book and
i always love learning things
whenever i read uh books like this but
uh but it was about the so-called
theoretical virtues and you guys talk
about the theoretical virtues
and this is in a paper which i'll put in
the show notes by michael peace is that
how you say it michael keys
yeah and he has this uh paper which is
kind of an update to like thomas kuhn or
karl popper
but it really i'm gonna put it up on the
screen and it's the different virtues
that a theory must have and i want to go
over it and kind of
ask you guys on the scorecard where do
you rank
the big bang in other words where would
you rank the big bang according to this
rubric of scoring
possibilities to eliminate to weed out
or as you know my friend and i eric
weinstein have been talking about a
sieve
a sieve to say what is valuable about a
particular model be it
theory of everything or an alternate to
the big bang so the first evidential
virtue
the first uh of the 12 virtues
is evidential accuracy a theory fits the
empirical evidence well
regardless of causal claim how would you
say luke that the
big bang theory matches up on that scale
of
actually matching up well with empirical
evidence
the big bang itself being uh normally uh
associated with a singularity in the
early universe
well that's that's a distinction that we
make carefully in the book there's
the big bang as that moment supposedly
when everything was is compressed into a
single point and
a massive you know whatever uh and then
there's what actually cosmologists call
the big bang theory which is in the past
the universe was hotter and denser than
today
and and and whether
the thing we're really testing is that
second idea whether the first one is
true is another question
entirely uh but in terms of the data so
we we
lay out in the book sort of six pieces
of evidence that we think the big bang
handles quite well
and certainly it handles well enough
that someone with a new idea out there
had better handle it at least as well as
the big bang because if you're not
that's that's how you buy your ticket to
this this show
you here's the things that you can
explain beyond that if you can do better
on other areas then that's great
so uh for example um the relationship
between redshift and distance
the fact that we see redshifted galaxies
everywhere in the universe and the
redshift increases the further away
that you look it's something that's very
nicely explained by the big bang theory
uh the the spectrum of the cosmic
microwave background
there was a time when everything in the
universe was at the same temperature
at some point the light got released
from that
system and it's still hanging around now
at a much lower temperature
but with that characteristic signature
of light and matter perfectly coupled
um but there's still open opportunities
there
as we talk about in the book for example
when we predict what
nuclear reactions in the early universe
uh
will create in terms of the the species
of the elements
we get helium about right we get
deuterium about right you know one
proton one neutron
we get um um
sorry helium-3 uh about right but then
we get lithium wrong
by a factor of about three so we're not
miles out but it's still enough is
really important to some of us
yeah yeah yeah yeah but if if some other
theory this is the point
if you can buy your ticket on all those
other
pieces of data you can then swoop in
explain that lithium better and then
you'll have one up on the big bang what
you can't do is just ignore all that
other stuff
try to explain the lithium problem and
think that you've made some progress
so i also note that um there is the
presence as i said
in the book of of counter
revolutionaries of of those in the past
who have done
a great service in cosmology i would say
orthodox cosmology like jeff burbidge uh
like another uh another pioneer who is
also at ucsd nobel prize winner alvin
who had a model of the universe plasma
cosmology we're going to go over that
you're going to give it your grade
and you know if you look at it from uh
outside the physics
perspective of orthodox physics
perspective um
it's sometimes tough for even a
professional physicist like
us or astrophysicist or astronomer like
the three of us to really
how do we separate out the genius from
kind of the the draws for example fred
hoyle
who we all know and you guys talk
extensively in the book about he made
tremendous contributions some say he
should have won the nobel prize shared
it with fowler
uh for nuclear synthesis uh within
elements
and and yet he maintained till his dying
day
that the universe was a manifestation of
a cyclic
quasi-steady state model we he called it
but nowadays we'd kind of refer to it as
a
type of cyclic model um or or perhaps as
a as an internally reproducing
universe and we have models like that uh
they're they're promulgated by people by
the name of linday and guth
how do we separate out uh grant how do
we separate out
the kind of draws from the wheat how do
we know when even an eminent scientist
who's proven his metal
no pun intended to get that guys uh with
oil
um but how do we know that this person's
gone into crack
crank land or or not how how can we tell
as professional
physicists well so look i've been in
this game for a while and i've met
a lot of very smart people and some of
the most intriguing ones are the ones
who are not only
smart but have a lot of ideas right and
fred hoyle was definitely one of those
that had ideas from the as you said from
the genius
almost to the crackpot or even into the
crackpot with some of his
stuff to do with life from space etc
um i think you if you've got somebody
like hoyle who's putting something
forward you've got to take it seriously
and you've got to take a look at it but
then it's this question of
how does it do when you know confronted
with the evidence of the universe and of
course
for fred hoyle and steady state and the
wheel started to come off that very very
quickly because
you know in the 1950s there was the
first observations of the deep universe
and it was realized that the distant
universe is not the same as the nearby
universe
and clearly there's evolution going on
and what you saw is that fred hoyle
was jerry rigging at some stage and you
know
shoring up his his ideas by introducing
components that didn't make the model
any simpler it just made it more complex
to explain the observations
so you know it i think there's not just
a simple one sieve you can apply and say
this idea is crazy and this idea isn't
you've got to go through the stages of
how does it compare
against the universe and when of course
when steady state was first
proposed which was in the very late
1940s
it was on par essentially with the the
big bang
idea right they were they in terms of
the observations
they were um you know on par it was the
observations that came
later that caused the problems so yeah
it's
i said it's i don't think it's a
one-step process um i like to take
most ideas seriously but yeah they often
fall apart
when confronted with nature yeah so that
is one of the virtues although
i think you know so let's let's take a
mental dunkin experiment uh you guys
talk about these as well in this book uh
we're talking about
the cosmic revolutionaries handbook with
the two authors uh garrett lewis
and luke barnes joining us uh well deep
into the future
and uh this this book really details a
bunch of different
uh ideas on how your theory
if it is to supersede the big bang
uh must adhere to or must must uh
explain as much as it does
but add on to it perhaps predictive
power but again if we go back in time
a lot of the great breakthroughs were
retrodictions in other words they were
explaining things that were already
understood
and i get a lot of these questions
nowadays you know i'm going to explain
why there's three you know generations
of fermions or whatever
why you know hadrons divide into these
two different classes
um but uh but in reality you know a lot
of it is sort of
appealing to one of the one of the
theoretical virtues that i
disagree with which which is listed in
um in keys paper
which i'll put up and it is that uh it's
an aesthetic virtue it's essentially
that
uh it should be pleasure it evokes
beauty your theory t
evokes beauty which which i couldn't
disagree with more let me
let me try to get to that on my preview
screen here
uh article yeah there we go so here it
is i'm showing you guys can't see it but
it's the aesthetic virtues of which
there are three beauty simplicity and
unification
uh beauty the theory evokes aesthetic
pleasure and properly functioning and
sufficiently
informed person so let's go back to 1604
i was a man named kepler who made some
contributions to
our understanding of astronomy and
physics and even had a theory of
everything at least
for the organization of the solar system
that was quite
parsimonious it was simple it relied on
platonic solids
uh we can go back further frank wilcheck
writes a lot about pythagoras he spends
a lot of time talking about pythagoras
whose h index has not moved much lately
uh but is still nevertheless
quite well respected uh and then unifies
explains more facts than rivals with the
same amount of theoretical content
uh do you think that we are sort of
overwhelmed by this
notion of beauty uh or aesthetic
pleasure
in sufficiently informed persons i'll
start with luke in that question
yeah so this is an interesting question
it's it's be it's coming to focus a bit
more
so being hossenfelder has been quite her
book lost in math or
something else elsewhere yeah has sort
of
shown a light on this in particular
because on the back of
of well naturalness arguments and which
seem like
sort of beauty arguments you know
we're looking for supersymmetry using
billions and billions and billions of
dollars
so there's a lot at stake in that sort
of um
in this discussion i'd say these are
these are theoretical virtues these are
not theoretical
mandates if you've got it then that's
you know all
sort of center as parameters it's all
all things being equal
i mean you can't help us as a physicist
when you first see general relativity
you know you've got some hard work to do
to get yourself up to the maths
that you need to understand it but it is
a
deeply like it's an amazing theory it's
a very beautiful thing
um if it you know there's a there's a
quote from einstein that um
if the data went against it then he'd
feel sorry for god or something like
that you know
the theory is correct uh yeah the
universe actually
follows things too right but i i
so i think more than that
yeah so i think it's it's a virtue i i
should say
what mike's doing in this paper is
there's there's been a bunch of other
papers and he's a historian of science
not a philosopher of science although he
covers in that area and not a scientist
he's trying to to not say this is how
science must be done
but what are the sorts of things that
scientists themselves
have presented as being here's a reason
to think my theory is a good theory
and so my theory is remarkably simple
while still doing all the other things
does seem to be a bonus
and i want to take a little pause to
advertise for the cause
i am uh i am actually being approached
by advertisers to advertising the into
the impossible podcast i have not yet
accepted uh such uh such such
remuneration
and i don't know if i will but i do want
to mention this book
which i am not being paid to endorse uh
i really love this book
the cosmic revolutionaries handbook
written by grant lewis and
luke barnes i want to congratulate grant
first
uh being uh uh selected as the vice
chancellor's award-winning
uh researcher at the university of
sydney so congratulations for that garen
thank you very much i saw that on
linkedin so congratulations that's
really cool
um now i want to do something that i
don't normally do but since sometimes
we we get some fun interactions i want
to ask you guys
i looked over your amazon us ratings of
the book there's 38
uh reviews of your book written or star
reviews
i want to ask you if you'll play along
in this game that i call
high and low
yeah why not absolutely
i'll leave that in your capable hands
foreign
that's a little oh okay so it's not bad
i was stealing myself
um yeah i'm quite happy with that
i i tr as you said i translated into
qriket language first but other than
that i'm quite happy with
with it
oh that's a that's a that's a bit of a
minefield as luke mentioned our previous
book touched on that a bit more and um
received
a broader range of of comments um
look the question of origins where did
where did we come from
um and you know and where are we going
even
i think that that sparks interest in an
awful lot of people right
even if it's um if it's a religious or
even as just a scientific kind of
question um
yeah i
i yeah i i'm gonna pass over to lou
because i think he's thought more about
this question than i have
so so to give the game away i'm i'm a
theist
and and and garrett isn't so in our last
book the final chapter was just a
conversation
between us about what we think all of
this means and no no particular
conclusions were reached
but it is a fun thing to chat about
uh it does genesis uh invite people to
develop their own cosmological models
well
empirically it's it's engineers who
wanting to tell us what they think about
the universe not specifically
well i don't specifically get religious
people telling me that
um as myself i still don't get
that more i i don't get that
guys hold on one second i'm just gonna
check um my audience is saying they
don't hear it
uh they don't hear my side right now i'm
just gonna
check my own feed here the audio to some
it's
some it's a pleasure not to hear me to
others it's
a deep regret let's see let me put it on
here
got you back all right good okay so i
think i'm back um
okay so sorry so you were saying there's
these versus uh versus non-theist
uh necessarily but uh luke you're
finishing that up
and say grant do you want to add
anything to that
well i do actually i think often it's
the opposite
so what we get is people who don't like
the notion of a big bang as
to them it mimics the story of creation
and
at some level they think it's bringing
uh religion to science by having this
birth
to the universe and what we want to try
to get across in this book of course is
that it's really a scientific
quest right it's a scientific question
on where did the universe come from your
interpretation
and your inner beliefs that that in my
mind is your business but in terms of
science
this is the way we understand the
universe
very good so um let's get back to this
uh these theoretical virtues and vices
maybe that would be another another
subject of the book
and getting back to this notion of um of
whether or not
you know somebody who is attempting to
overthrow the big bang
and what their motivation might be
that's something that always strikes me
i
i sort of feel like i don't know if you
guys play this game in australia like
dungeons and dragons um i don't know is
that a popular game down under
yeah yeah so yeah that's right yeah so
then they you have this
notion like or on risk when you beat
somebody you get like all their armies
you get their hit points or whatever in
dungeons and dragons
it always seemed to me that if you were
to you know the notion that i get is if
uh if i
overcome this guy einstein you know i'll
sort of be more famous than einstein
i will you know if i displace him i'll
be the most famous person who ever lived
in science
because uh because the
um uh let's see hold on wait a second
i'm just making sure
okay good so they can still hear me um
yeah so i just
i always wonder what is the sort of
motivation for people that are already
established like
for example fred hoyle didn't win the
nobel prize
like our guest tomorrow frank wilcheck
uh as long as we get the 15 000
subscribers in the next nine hours
uh but uh but nevertheless he did
uh he did have a tremendous amount of
attention respect and even
uh claimed evidence for the quasi-steady
state even going to his grave
uh believing that and i i should say i'm
going to have on giant narlikar in the
next few weeks
he's uh one of fred hoyle's closest
partners and collaborators
and he's uh he lives in india right now
he'll be on the show we'll talk with him
about some of the questions you raise
but they still believe it there's in
other words there's
it's gone beyond the the notion of well
you know there's there there was this um
you know epoch
at which the universe was steadily
creating a tiny bit of matter now they
claim that things like dark energy
is really sort of a form of what they
call the creation field you talk about
that's in the book
what do you say to people that you know
have kind of they're on the right track
um and maybe anticipated stuff like the
accelerating expansion
um but just won't let their theories be
falsified so to speak
well for fred hoyle it was the actual
uh the birth of the universe that he
didn't like he didn't like this notion
that the universe had a finite age
uh which is why he came up with this uh
you know the
um the complete capernaum principle
which whichever one
a perfect copernicus cosmological
principle yeah that the universe is
unchanging over time
and that was his motivation he just he
just didn't like the notion of the birth
of the universe
and actually when you talk to a lot of
people you you realize is that
a lot of it comes down to taste a lot of
people don't
like relativity because at some level
they don't understand it
right so this notion of expanding space
in the universe
it doesn't make any sense to them so
something else must explain to you
there's something they can understand
and you mentioned alfin right so plasmas
and electromagnetic fields
people sort of understand those and this
makes more sense
than expanded space so they want to base
their cosmology on that
rather than the sort of standard picture
so yeah the and and of course the
the problem is is that people are people
and no matter how
we sort of separate the person from the
science we say that science
is you know there's no person in there
it has to come in at some level so
personal tastes and likes and biases
feed into what people want to and don't
want to accept
so now let's take a look through the
book again i hate it when authors are
asked to
you know essentially divulge the
entirety of the book and
uh you know people people are not
encouraged to buy the book i want
everybody to buy this book multiple
copies
uh it's available on all different
platforms amazon as well as
um as well as uh
um a kindle and audiobook too at least i
was able to find it
i want to go to some modern incarnations
of ways to evade the big bang
including uh the the winner of the 2020
or co-winner of the 2020 nobel prize
sir roger penrose who was on the show uh
last month
right after he won the nobel prize for a
second
so i'll jump in
yeah um i i sort of think of these
as being a prequel so what we talk about
in the
in the book is this the standard well
for the most part we'll get on
the later chapters talk about a bit more
but the standard
in the past the universe was hotter and
denser
theory that big bang theory the standard
story
um we have to extend that model back
early enough
that we get the predictions of the light
elements correct
so when the universe is about a second
old
it has a temperature hold on one second
i'm losing this right the camera one
more time
what about now can anybody tell me can
you hear me now
i am changing the camera uh do you hear
me now
uh let's see tap my mic
sorry about this guys i have this fancy
camera set up and then it doesn't
provide
the most basic sound function now i hear
it on here
i think it's fine what about now we do
yes okay good sorry luke go ahead
all right so there's there's the
standard story
of of you know the original trilogy of
the the way the universe was from when
it was one second old to today
that's the story that the big bang if
we've got that bit of the story right it
predicts a whole bunch of stuff about
the universe
what that offers is the chance then to
write the bit beforehand there's the
standard story of the universe
extrapolated
before say one second ish after the big
bang
or there's the inflationary models which
change that story they say
it didn't just have a very fast
acceleration it had
an exponential acceleration at some
point very early
and what penrose is doing is he's
writing a different prequel
to the to the original novel he's got a
different set of prequels there
uh and uh alternative models to
inflation are doing the same thing
the important thing about those is the
reason they explain the data of the big
bang theory is that they at
about one second they arrive back at the
same point
a universe which is really hot which has
a certain ratio
of light to matter which has a certain
amount of dark
matter and dark energy as long as you
start you know
you're thinking of whatever you know you
know lord of the rings as long as you
get back to the start of the lord of the
rings the rest of that story will play
out the same
you can then replace the hobbit or
whatever came before with your own story
but as long as you arrive back there
you're all right for what follows
so i i tend to think of it that way um
and so
if these models if they're not just
going to be
speculation in a part of the universe
where we can't test them
they're going to have to provide
something new some new information which
is what penrose is trying to do
um what about now let's see if i can
hear myself now
yeah sorry about those guys we'll edit
this out you know before we
send it to the bbc or the abc
i can't i can't hear myself so the
problem is
uh i wonder if it's this camera
they say when i change cameras
all right now they're hearing me okay
now they're back all right good all
right so what i was saying was
um we have this notion that cosmology
can
sort of explain how it itself came into
existence in other words how
the universe's initial conditions come
to be
but um but cosmology doesn't really deal
with that
i mean do you feel like people make that
mistake very frequently in other words
trying to understand how initial
conditions came
back and came into being is not really a
part of the big bang itself right
yeah that's i mean that's right so
that's why we focused on
things like explaining the observational
evidence that we have in the universe
around us but
that question of the instant the birth
of the universe
is really a separate question and we
find that and
look it's partially our fault as
scientists we we mash the words together
without defining what we're talking
about quite often and people there are
people that don't like the notion of the
initial singularity
whereas most cosmologists don't even
think about it right that's not their
day job
they're studying the universe around us
so they are separate questions
but they get mashed into one
yeah luke uh what do you make of people
that um do want to really
pigeonhole the initial conditions into
the theory of the dynamics
well i mean this is a really the point
that wheeler was making was that
uh there's no law of initial conditions
in in every law of the universe that we
found it's a dynamical law so it tells
you how the universe
changes but not to to that you have to
add where it started from so then you
know how it changed you know how it is
um this is sort of true of every law
we've seen
and so all that means is it's not that
the initial conditions
are just something we can't talk about
at all
it's just it's got to be a separate
postulate at some point you get down to
the point where
this is where i was confused in like
first first year physics that
you know the schrodinger equation of
general of of sorry of quantum mechanics
went up on the board
and you asked where did that come from
and ultimately the answer is something
like
well from schrodinger he just thought
that that was a good idea and then we tr
we thought oh what if the universe was
like that and then off we go
there's at some point there's no deeper
derivations to be made you just say
what if the universe was like this and
as a part of that you have to say what
if the universe started off like this
so it's very important this is the point
we make in the book
there's the the part of cosmology which
is trying to use the model we have uh to
try to predict the data that we see
when we talk about the singularity we're
not doing that sort of stuff
we're saying here's the theoretical
ideas we have what if we push to them
really hard towards the start of the
universe
what might they tell us and the answer
of that has always got to be
something speculative it it there are
some interesting clues there
you know it's a conversation we can have
it's just a very different thing from
can i explain some data so i want to uh
walk through a couple of other ideas
that i took away from this book
but not before really visiting this this
topic that you brought up in the book
which is the kind of
notion for uh the necessity of
a grand unified theory a theory of
everything
that unifies gravity with the other uh
three
higher energy forces you do mention it
in the book
um it's not you know as as prominent uh
because it's not really a book about
fundamental physics
but nevertheless you do mention it in
the context of both the big bang
and in the uh context of
black holes and singularities thereof um
what do you assess
right now the kind of a score card for
theories of everything there are so many
of them we've had on
discussions over the summer live streams
about different theories of everything
there seem to be a lot coming out now
and the question is why is that
happening
uh what do you guys take what's your
take uh grant let's start with you
uh what's what's the take that you have
on why is there such a proliferation
of theories of everything i'll give you
my short thing and then you guys can
respond to it just as you will
but my feeling is we don't know that
singularities exist at all in nature
in other words there's no evidence of a
singularity of an infinite quantity
let alone an infinite quantity that then
smoothly transitions over time
you know as my kids say you know i love
you two times infinity
well half of infinity is still is still
infinity right so once it cools down
uh you know from infinity it's still
infinity so the big bang
infinity presents us with problems the
black hole
you know firewall prevents us from
seeing the singularity that
could be at the center of a black hole
so those are the only two
contexts in which i'm aware of that we
need a theory of everything so what do
you guys
make of that why do why do you think
there is so much effort put on
marrying quantum mechanics to gravity
when the two situations that i can think
about
aren't really ever going to be testable
so i'll start with a story i i began my
undergraduate degree in 1987 at the
university of london
and one of my tutors was michael green
one of the
fathers of uh string theory and we were
told in 1987
that any day now string theory is going
to crack it and we will have
a unified theory of gravity etc
here we are you know 30 odd years later
and i feel that we haven't really moved
on that
far and i'm starting to wonder if the
proliferation of um ideas is is almost
an act of desperation in that
you know there's been an awful lot of
investment in
strings and then brains and all these
other ideas
and it is proven that you know very
difficult to come up with a single
unified theory that seems to explain
everything
and we need it in cosmology because even
though we ignore
that instant of creation in the book it
is still
it's still a door that we want to look
through we definitely want to look back
and ask the question
where did this universe come from is it
a one-off
or is it part of something bigger and
until we can
work out how gravity and the other
forces play nicely together
we have that theoretical uh wall at you
know twiddle the plank time whatever it
is
that we cannot see through and
everything that's been done to date
is effectively you know jerry rigged at
some level we've
shoehorned gravity and the other forces
together to to
peer what we think we're appearing
through the door but we really want to
open it and ask the question where the
universe came from
so i'm getting a question from one of my
uh dedicated listener simon farmer
and simon's asking how long after the
big bang which
he may mean the origin of time as
hawking would refer to it
how long after the big bang is a theory
considered part of the big bang theory
a second a year the epoch of
reionization a recombination
when when should we rightfully consider
uh
you know adding on to the big bang and
trying to revolt against it
uh luke so for me
and i'm taking this from martin reece
actually
it's the initial in the show upcoming oh
very good
yeah he's fascinating uh for me it's
it's uh it's the initial conditions of
nucleosynthesis
so wherever you need to start your story
of the universe
and in the standard model it's about a
second ish after the beginning
in order that you then calculate the
nuclear reactions that happen during
that
first three minutes or so and at the end
of that you get your predictions for
the abundance of the light elements in
the universe
that's sort of the first point where
there's a relic of
of that part of the story there's
there's the story we tell of that first
three minutes
and the leftovers of that is all the
helium in the universe around us
so for me that's anything that happened
before then doesn't
leave really a relic so much as long
as i said before as long as you arrive
at one second
in the state that the standard story
tells
you you should be okay so for me that's
the sort of cut off
point if we found a relic from even
earlier
say uh a background of neutrinos
uh a gravitational wave background then
suddenly the story that we can actually
test in some sense directly or
it's a long time ago so it doesn't seem
very direct
that that's that the start of that story
would go even earlier but
things like inflation um
again a sort of part of that prequel
yeah
i think i think i agree with luke you
know this started nuclear synthesis
that's where we're confident but as you
push back the number of questions
just keeps increasing our uncertainty
keeps increasing so we you know at some
point we've got to hit the question of
you know
where did the baryons come from and why
is there the
the number of baryons in the universe
today on all those kind of questions
you push back further and it just
becomes more uncertain
so you know it's not like there's a
dividing line like this is certain
and this is just old speculation just
becomes murky and misty as we go back
yeah it's actually interesting that you
point that out and you know again
your book is unique cosmic
revolutionaries handbook
uh because it you know it really goes
through a checklist and we'll go through
a score card in the last few minutes i
did this most recently with shelly
glashow
so you guys are in good company of
course his book is significantly older
uh than your book but so there's more
time for f's to accumulate as did happen
with my report cards
or as you blokes would say marks i'm
sure but um but not the marks that were
normally thought of as this fist in the
revolutionary handbook right
that's a different marks with an x just
kidding folks um
i want to go back to this notion of of
like when does it start when does the
big bang start so you're
one of the folks who wrote your
approbation or your blurb
as we say the sean carroll and sean has
a particularly nice concise way of
saying
uh what is the big bang it's not
necessarily the origin of time
it's sort of the end of our ignorance so
going backwards from today
when can we have go back as far as we
can until we can't say with certainty
what conditions in the universe were
like and for me that's the big bang era
of the big bang nucleosynthesis
which luke you pointed out it seems to
me and it just kind of struck me just
now as the three of us are chatting
is that the people that have a problem
nowadays and want to do revolution it's
really against inflation
and as as luke you said if you were to
obtain um
you know actually both of you guys said
this you know evidence from some other
uh messenger may that be gravitational
waves hopefully
again as you guys point out the uh
there's a certain cosmologist by the
name of brian keating quoted in the book
um and uh but nevertheless you know we
could have
evidence of a different type of
phenomena that would give
either more credence i would say that
maybe you guys agree
if we discovered the cosmic neutrino
background that would um that would
bolster the
bayesian confidence in the big bang hot
big bang
it wouldn't do anything for cosmogenesis
though the way that gravitational waves
would
what do you guys think do you think the
problem that people have like penrose
and steinhardt and turok
and others is with the big bang or is it
with the
or is it with inflation
i think it's a little bit of both isn't
it i mean the
the for some people
again people are people some people
inflation is one of those things that
they they feel it's rock solid it's
something that happened to the universe
but to others it's somehow some sort of
add-on right it's some sort of
almost um ad hoc addition that solves
some problems that might not actually be
problems
so i think there is a little bit of
still unease around the question of
inflation because there is no
um slam dunk this is the evidence that
conclusively demonstrated that we had a
period of inflation
so if we if we don't have inflation then
we still have questions around the
properties of the universe
their flatness horizon which may or may
not be problems
that you still need to address and i
think that's what you know where
steinhardt is coming from
and also with regards to roger penrose i
mean
i haven't looked at what he's done we
know his mind is somewhat different to
us right to him
everything's a geometric shape and for
him it makes sense to
to join singularities to singularities
in a geometric sense
and that's the sort of basis of of his
his
his picture um
yeah i said i think some people just
feel uncomfortable
with the lack of concrete evidence of
inflation
so you do need to have some sort of
alternative to explain the properties of
the universe we see around us
so i want to close before we get to the
rubric and and i want to have time to
cover some of my favorite
ways to beat the big bang um you know
maybe your next book
uh will be about you know theories of
everything in a sense that you know
almost every day i make this joke you
know probably too much
too often than i should but but you know
i get all these emails about theories of
everything but nobody ever proposes an
experiment of everything
you know it's like and i wondered you
know i was thinking about that today
is that because and then this is not to
denigrate my you know some of my best
friends or theorists you know they
they call me their plumber or
electrician i'm fine with that as long
as you can handle my questions but
um but the point being that a lot of it
is is
is that there's a supply and demand
problem it's it's easier it just happens
to be true
it's easier to create a theory than it
is to build an experiment it's just
it's no doubt about it uh and i'm
wondering if there's like
you know a whole bunch of low-hanging
fruit or or data that
is it already been collected you guys
give this wonderful link to this program
which i wasn't aware of
um and i was only dismayed that it
wasn't available on my iphone
this alter big bbn where you can change
uh bbn
big bang nucleosynthesis code which has
been around since uh my friend and
uh former professor at stanford bob
wagner and his team
were doing this in the 60s and he's
still going strong he was a
you know an influence really strong
influence in my career
but you have to agree with it it doesn't
matter what you do in your
in your theory you have to agree with
bbn at least except for lithium
again more important to some of us than
others but the point being
there are ways to test it and compare to
actually existing data so my concern is
you know when somebody emails me
something what should i give them should
i give them besides giving you know
telling him to buy your book
and and go online to get cosmic
revolutionaries handbook which is a
phenomenal book
um what else should i do should it be
you know can you can you rederive all
the literature do you understand all the
literature certainly that's a
prerequisite
um but again people like alfin burbidge
you know hoyle they were pretty
conversant with the literature uh
so you know what what should we do as as
a sort of practicing physicist with a
desire to do outreach and communicate
with the public they pay our taxes
sorry they don't pay our taxes yet their
taxes pay our salaries right
i'm at least i'm a public employee i
assume you guys are at some level as
well
anyway what should we do we get an email
theory of everything
alternate to the big bang step one what
do i tell them
well
which is of course the right answer um
yeah so
i think as you you mentioned this before
and this was quite important to us
uh that we we weren't just saying we're
the scientists
you're the layperson let us handle this
the point of the book is
look there's a way that science works
it's a human activity so it's never
going to be perfect but it's not
arbitrary either
here are the rules here's why we do what
we do here's why we publish
here's why we go and talk to other
scientists here's why we use
mathematical models
here's the data that we're after all
right that's the game
okay if you want to play the game there
it is if you don't
play it properly you know we're going to
ignore your work not because there's
some sort of arbitrary rule there but
because you're
you know you're not explaining the data
or you haven't actually made predictions
or something like that
uh there's an important lesson there
with bob wagoner actually i
i don't know him personally like you do
but uh his
supervisor was he worked with hoyle
right yeah
so um this is a point we make in the
book he
hoyle understands the big bang not just
his own theory
he understands the big bang theory well
enough that he can work with a student
to make the predictions of the big bang
theory for it so
there's an idea behind the big bang
theory which is precise enough
that regardless of what you think about
the theory you can at least derive its
predictions
this is something we so often don't see
from the people who email us
we see someone with an idea that's
entirely in their own head
and no one else in the universe explains
it i
understand it except for them all right
um i just don't i like my audience why
are you listening to this
so leave a thumbs up first of all
subscribe please
if you haven't but leave a thumbs up if
you've ever
received uh a an email
or a comment or a question if you've uh
if
about a theory of everything or a new
model for the big bang and leave a
thumbs down
if you personally out there have a
theory of everything
and or a theory of how the universe may
have started grant what's your take
on you know kind of where do people
start after buying your book in audio
and listening to it and
reading it in physical form where do
they start well i think
the starting point has to be
understanding the lay of the land
today what we often find is that people
are focused on observations and
measurements that were you know
people still present hubble's original
25 galaxies to us and just say how can
you conclude that the universe is
expanding from this data
without realizing that in the intervene
in almost 100 years we've now
observed hundreds of thousands if not
millions of galaxies
so it's understanding where we're at and
realizing that cosmology
is no longer focused on really redshifts
and
and quasars but there are other places
where the worries are
what we're worried about is the
small-scale universe what happens
uh with regards to individual galaxies
and the processes and dark matter in
galaxies and that question of the birth
of the universe
so what cosmologists have focused upon
are not necessarily the data these
people are looking at
[Music]
okay so i'm asking my readers now my
listeners now they are
actually tweeting and and thumbing up
and thumbing down so i've gotten some
good
until now we had an unblemished streak
of 25 thumbs up but now it's
we're getting some thumbs down boys i'm
sorry to tell you that um
i'm going to read you some names of some
uh of some theories of everything
sorry certain alternate cosmological
models and without going into them
i want you to uh tell me if this is from
a crank or a legitimate scientist first
one
a rotating universe a revolutionary
theory of everything
a brief history of timelessness
so a rotated universe that was um
uh oh it's just a girdle that's right
that was uh
very good girdle's birthday present to
einstein
yeah we discovered in our last book yeah
yeah yeah so yeah so so that one
is a is a a real cosmology but it
doesn't look like it fits our universe
it also has time travel in it which
would make it pretty cool right
so uh so that was the first one the
second one was oh i haven't got the
second one but yes that was oh that was
one long title
wow yeah that was one long title exactly
and he actually says that
uh is the universe rotating yet is the
last question girdle
asked on his deathbed so it's kind of
interesting that observers are still
looking for signatures of a rotating
universe yeah
people are looking looking for
polarization of distant sources to see
if there's a rotation signature
what's happening or that a rotating
universe or the multiverse
i guess if there's a multiverse some of
them have got to be rotating so
yeah yeah that makes the multiverse
weirder yeah so
uh when i talk about that also i'll be
talking to lord martin reese the
astronomer royal
who will read my horoscope as he does
for the queen he promises me
uh he uh he came up with an
anisotropically expanding universe so
it's it's really not that far away and
that's actually how he came up with the
idea
for cmb polarization so again uh folks
stay tuned please subscribe to the
channel it really helps me out if i get
to 15 000 subscribers
but in the next three minutes i will uh
have a live
chat your opportunity and you blokes
included from australia you'll get up
super early yeah 9am pacific tomorrow
and you will be able to live chat with a
nobel prize winner
frank wilczyk who's a wonderfully
interesting human being i'll talk to him
about some of his notions because he is
one of these people
who like grant's a professor back in
cambridge i guess he said
was uh predicting and promising super
symmetry
string theory all sorts of other things
even in his most recent book
so it's quite fascinating to do that um
i want to go through really quickly
in the remaining two minutes that we
have left
some other models we talked about the
plasma cosmology
um i want to talk about like these kind
of
models that don't feature an
inflationary epoch
but also don't have the big bang so in
or don't have a singularity
within them and that is uh things like
the conformal cyclic cosmology or
perhaps uh the steinhardt's model of the
bouncing
cosmology which has a classical
transition from
previous cycle to current cycle when we
think about these models
they don't feature inflation that's sort
of their virtue
they can be falsified that's a virtue
right if we observe
gravitational waves neither neither one
predicts gravitational waves
and even penrose claims we've seen
evidence so-called hawking points i've
disputed with him
uh on on actually on our interview
when we think about these uh alternative
ways the universe could have began
begun um if you had to hedge your bets
you know ways all other than the big
bang before we get to the final couple
of ones
that i'm gonna uh bring up that i'm
interested in reviewing
what one has sort of the most appeal to
each of you i'll start with luke
so i i have a friend who's a quantum
cosmologist at cambridge who
who who points out that science proceeds
in a really
interesting way it proceeds by
publishing things that they think that
other scientists will find interesting
um and so where you have these
theoretical models
sometimes they're just there because
there's so the singularity
theorems that what what penrose are
talking are famous for
are kind of um
if you want to have a model that doesn't
have a singularity you have to jump
through these hoops and backflip over
this and then
and then do that and so there's an
interest there for if you're a theorist
to go well
watch this and then they produce a model
which backflips over and then jumps
through the hoop and
through the fire and all this sort of
stuff so i
i think these models are interesting
sometimes they're just sort of a proof
of concept hey look i can avoid a
singularity theorem
um but having said that uh
again for what we were focused on in the
book
as long as you get back to the standard
story you can write your own prequel and
as long as it predict
you know produces predictions um that
are in some sense novel
you might have a chance of actually
doing something that's better than than
the big bang or having your prequel
become part of the canon part of the
real story
of actually extending the the big bang
picture
in some sort of way congrats why would
you choose if you had a bet
uh the aussie dollars um
well look i i i don't mind the
multiverse picture telling the truth i
actually
i do think that um to me
it helps me sleep at night to think that
this universe is one in a chain of
of universes we came from some
pre-existing structure there will be
some structure after us whatever after
means
i i don't i don't find the uh the
notion of an initial singularity in the
start of time particularly comforting
so i like to think that we're just part
of something bigger
and uh last thing before we get to this
final scorecard um which i definitely
am going to do i want to um i have a
question from one of my friends roger
perlman
another roger p and he's talking about
uh and he brings up the point about the
hubble tension
so as you know we have a great deal of
anxiety as cosmologists which is why
we're so interested in lithium
i'll stop making that joke uh but the uh
with the point being that we have all
these
controversies so to speak i actually had
a so-called great debate part two with
wendy friedman adam reese
uh sarah seeger janet levin uh david
spurgle and we talked about this
you know pretty radically sized you know
five sigma
you know discrepancy between
measurements of the hubble constant
early times late times
and on the back of the book you guys
talk about you know why should we trust
these cosmologists you know big bang you
know everything started in a big bang
invisible dark matter
invisible dark energy hubble tension
we have all sorts of other you know
possible controversies that could arise
um why do we trust it it's got you know
kind of some bizarre features to it
unlike say you know quantum
electrodynamics not like oh all of a
sudden there's a quantum electronic
elf and and the elf is what's doing the
uh feynman diagram sort of
you know we don't have that it's it's
not like extremely precise 12 decimal
places and then all of a sudden this is
wacky kind of bolt-on thing not
like wormholes and parallel universes
we don't have that in other branches of
much more you know kind of conventional
physics so
how do you address the skeptic who says
you guys don't even know what 99 of the
universe is made of
and you've got these crazy ideas that
are off by 120 orders of magnitude uh
luke what do you say to such a skeptic
a revolutionary so what we say is go and
go and do better
one of the points we make in the book is
um no one's really that happy with
dark energy so uh dark matter and dark
energy especially so
we keep saying you know the comments
that there's a conspiracy amongst
cosmologists they want to preserve
their existing theories i think my
impression is we'd all throw dark matter
away tomorrow if
if we had a better model uh it's just we
we're not going to make a move
from a model that works even if there's
bits of it we don't understand
to no model at all that's not a move
we're ever going to make
like you got to show us somewhere better
we're not just going to jump into a
vacuum and just float free for
for for a while uh that that's what i'd
say
yes there are problems the reason we're
here is because we don't have a better
solution
but you know if you've got one they
haven't said tell us
and uh okay so let's finish up by the
kind of rubric the scorecard
that you guys mentioned i'm gonna try
not to lose my
my screen and this is risky or lose my
audio so people tell me if i lose the
audio
but i do want to do this i'm going to
add and sharing my screen
these are the 10 ways to building
beating the big bang and building a
better universe
are you guys okay if i put this in the
show notes because what i'm gonna
propose
is that we um is that i use this
and i ask my audience to come up with a
uh with a um a version of this an analog
of this
but for theories of everything so
hopefully you guys will do a great
service
to physics and let's review it uh as
it's presented on the screen
first number one the rules according to
uh louis
and to barnes ten steps to beating the
big bang and building a better universe
know your enemy let me see first let me
ask can you guys hear me out there
hear me still okay great um
number one know thine enemy learn the
mathematical model that undergirds the
big bang theory
two prepare your rival your theory of
the universe needs to be precisely
formulated
ready for anyone to to use to predict
data
number three albers paradox you guys
spend a great amount of time and and
importantly and and appropriately so on
albers paradox has to explain
why the night sky is dark uh for
redshift and distance
why do we observe the light we receive
from distant galaxies almost always
redshifted
and why the redshift increases
proportionately to distance
next fading light explain why supernova
fade more slowly and while galaxies are
dimmer when their light is more
red-shifted
explain the cmb and why it has a
near-perfect black body spectrum you
don't as i point out you don't
as you point out you don't make it uh
you don't make it
mandatory that a theorist predict the
value of the
temperature that we observed today
that's not even part of the standard big
bang model
and i note that you know it's often not
really brought up
i don't remember if you guys mentioned
it or not but the
uh that the companion paper by dickie
peeble's role in wilkinson wilkinson
was my grand advisor uh was basically
never mentions the big bang once that
paper which is a companion and
explanation
uh oh now they're saying they lost the
audio uh
so i'll go back to this i'll just gonna
keep reading it i'll put it in the show
notes
let me see if i can hear myself uh
here i apologize again let's see here
no i can hear it i don't know what
they're talking about uh but anyway
getting back to this we um the final
ones after the cmb
which is the only point i was making is
that that was never predicted by
dickie that the big bang had to be
responsible for the temperatures seen by
pensions and wilson
in fact they talk about a previous cycle
in that paper so the con
the cyclic universe was still very much
in vogue uh
cosmic uh oh seven explain the lyman
alpha forest of course art wolf
was my late colleague art wolf was a
professor here ucsd has a lot of
good kind of cranky cosmologists but
also some outstanding
ordinary cosmologists you know
mainstream cosmologists ryan
cookie was here etc um do better oh
sorry cosmic oven
why does the universe have the essential
parts that we observe it essentially the
bbn
predictions we want to make sure we
understand why that is uh
and the amount of deuterium do better uh
outdo the big bang explain the lithium
abundance that we see in the universe
and uh folks like david tyler uh who's
also at ucsd
uh have looked into this problem trying
to understand it the last one may be
controversial with
some of my friends like my good friend
eric weinstein who's coming to visit
soon
might do a live stream if we hit 16 000
viewers by subscribers by friday
eric and i will do a live stream on this
channel for you guys to ask questions of
uh last one publish publish your theory
expose it
uh let it be vulnerable and i think uh i
agree with that
some people though say you know
sometimes theory is tentative and
provisional and we need to
you know kind of protect it before
publicizing it to the world
but i want to thank you guys for
publicizing your wonderful book
the cosmic revolutionaries handbook with
the world world
where can we find you guys on twitter uh
first of all luke garant
uh where can we find you guys on twitter
and uh what else are you up to next
what's your third book going to be about
okay so i'm at cosmic underscore
horizons
luke and i'm at luke barnes astro
uh and well we've got some ideas for the
next book one of them would be about uh
symmetry because
this kept on coming up in our previous
books that uh
the universe seems to to have a sort of
love-hate relationship with symmetry
some of the ones we
we we can imagine are out there and some
of the ones we can imagine are not the
way the universe is so
yeah just sort of explaining that very
good
uh well i'd love to hear about that yeah
the book by
frank wilcheck that i'm talking about
tomorrow is a beautiful
audio ryan oh you did ah okay so i think
i know why it's happening can you hear
me now
now okay yeah you're back good
uh so hopefully people out there can
hear me as well i want to just conclude
by saying
i've really enjoyed having you on the
into the impossible podcast i'm going to
encourage people to like this video
comment
subscribe etc please share the channel
with as many people as possible so we
can do a live chat
with frank wilcheck tomorrow and
possibly eric weinstein
on friday i want to thank my friend
miguel for making this wonderful
intro outro music that i'll play in a
second miguel is at yeti tears
on instagram and on twitter and i want
to thank you guys for a wonderful
interview and i wish you the best of
luck and may we all
continue the revolution the revolution
will be pushed on youtube
yes thank you thank you guys take care
cheers
[Music]
do
[Music]
all right everybody this has been the
into the impossible podcast with your
fearful host brian keating
now getting ready to sign off and get
ready for tomorrow if you guys would do
me the favor
subscribe comment and uh
and most of all get as many subscribers
as we can to the into the impossible
dr brian keating youtube channel so i
can continue to attract
amazing guests as i mentioned i've got
kamran vapha
that's already recorded you guys will
get that whether you subscribe or not i
hope you will subscribe
and uh but also frank wilcheck he's
going to be on at least twice
he's got a new book coming out but
tomorrow i'm going to talk about his
previous book a beautiful question
and that's really been a phenomenal book
for me to read and go over
as i said eric weinstein will actually
be here in person hopefully his covet
test passes
he'll be here in my office on friday and
we'll do a live stream together maybe
answering your questions
love to hear questions that you might
have we might go deep we might go
in and talk about uh god a little bit
more
but i really am encouraging him to
actually publish stuff and hopefully he
will
be working with me to to advance
geometric unity to the point where we
can compare it
to these theoretical virtues and also
this checklist
i want to ask you all out there to do me
a favor
uh besides you know sharing this channel
with as many people as possible
take a look in the comments in the
youtube description text box
i pasted they allowed me to cut and
paste this wonderful checklist that they
have
i'm going to put it in the in the box as
we speak and
what i want you guys to do is to do the
same as they've done
but not just for our theories of how the
universe could have started and
uh contrast or contradiction to the big
bang but do it for theories of
everything
because i get an awful lot of people
writing me about their theories of
everything and i love looking at them
and reading them
although i wish that they would present
them not to my
email account although you should email
you should join my email list but don't
send me your theories of everything
because i don't have much time for that
but to to read and respond i literally
get three or four a day
and they're usually like five to ten
pages long uh so
please do not do that but you can reach
out and
and perhaps uh make sure that your
theory of everything passes these tests
before you do it and these tests are
going to be in the youtube description
as we as we are speaking i just put it
in there this is for
the big bang but do the same for me
please
for theories of everything before you
send me a theory of everything
uh do the same kind of go run through
the same checklist
before uh sending it off and it'll save
you some trouble because
uh it's always good to get feedback
before you actually go live and expose
your
theory to criticism it's rare that some
theory gets published and everybody just
wants to
you know go out and measure it and and
perhaps uh you know dedicate years of
their career because we all have
only limited amount of time to do the
research that we do
um on the other hand i find it um
somewhat uh surprising that more people
don't look at existing data sets
to compare their theories with i'll put
a link to this alternate bbn calculator
so now i'm going to add a kind of a you
know a
a trick in in my parsing of different
proposals for big bang
alternatives and i'm going to add in
that you have to explain what the
abundances of these different elements
are
and so i'll put in a link to the alter
bbn this code that you can download for
free
unfortunately i think it's only c but
maybe one of you guys will
convert it into uh you know some python
script that we can run
in a jupiter notebook or something like
that those are all really cool things to
do
you can do a service and you might get
citations to it by working cosmologists
like me
anyway for now i want to encourage you
all to please uh tune in tomorrow
when i'll be talking to frank wilczyk
who's an amazing
brilliant individual and how often do
you get to talk to a person not like me
a loser
but a winner of one of these uh these
real
nobel prize medallions uh frank's an
amazing intellect he writes for the wall
street journal
he's got some controversial ideas and
some ideas that i think would make a
nice counterpoint to what we just heard
theories of everything and uh and even
the unification
of all fundamental forces of nature for
now i am signing off
uh please share this and uh and enjoy
this next episode this current episode
and our future episodes when we
again will go into the impossible i'll
play
the final song for my friend and yours
yeti tears the into the impossible
closing outro
by yeti tears here we go
i'm gonna put it up there thank you so
much miguel for making this lovely
lovely soundtrack
thank you for going into the impossible
you